darrel how are you so I'm pretty good
that's better than I deserve how can I
help
yes I was calling because I'm running
from a person we know and it's a
rent-to-own
so they had us purchase it from him and
we put 15,000 down on the home but now
they just came back and told us that
they want to get someone to finance
finance and now for it for us and about
20,000 and dead right now and we've been
trying to follow your step so far but
you know it's a little task but we're
going through it I was just trying to
see what would be a good way to go about
this now you've already given them
$15,000 and they change the deal yeah
they're moving out of out of town so or
out of the state so they're there one do
you not have a contract and have this in
writing yes we do
okay so the cont'd is a contract say
that at any time they can ask you to pay
them off um I'm not too sure about that
it will be unusual so is this just like
a friendship thing and they're asking
you to do this as a favor um I get I
guess so is it kind of sort of seems
like that but it's through my my wife is
as someone that she knows so I'm not too
sure I don't really speak to them too
much but I do every now and then when it
comes to to this situation and um you
know you know they were just saying that
they're about to move out of town in a
few months and that if we can get the
home financed that way they don't have
to hold the home through well I mean I
don't know if you can or not is the
problem because you put a down payment
on something that you didn't own
and it's going to be very very difficult
so I would have to refer you just to you
know get in touch with Churchill
mortgage and see if they can walk you
through a process by which you can use
that count that 15,000 that you gave up
front for this and so the house is not
in your name right no fair but they have
your 15,000 right yeah this is a really
bad deal Darrell it's a really bad deal
you've gotten yourself into a pinch I
hope you don't end up losing this money
um yeah I think it's a really good idea
to get the house into your name which
means you're going to have to get
financing for it it's not refinancing
but you'd have to get financing and the
problem is you've already put out your
down payment so what is the house worth
um right now we had a Prezy just come
through someone that we were trying to
finance it through and they appraised at
home right now at 135 okay and what is
your purchase price a hundred and fifty
five thousand well why would you pay a
hundred and fifty-five for a house
that's worth a hundred and thirty-five
but at the time it was it was more but
the old
where we're at it was big on the oil
boom so um it was it was a lot going for
a lot more than and now it has dropped
okay the price on the home my lord you
have any idea what end I have any idea
what these people know I'm sorry whether
you have any idea what these people owe
on the property they they bought the
property outright so they don't know
anything
oh well that's really good news okay
well I would have to sit down and talk
to them then and say all right listen
here's the deal the property dropped in
value from 155 to 135 have you told them
that yet yes sir we spoke about that and
they said they're they're willing to
work with us on that yeah mine
fifteen so you'd get a loan for 120 you
buy the house for 120 not once if it is
trying to trying to find someone of
finances right now is we don't really
have much honor on our credit but we
were pretty bad on on debt before I was
working an oil field and we made a lot
of dumb mistakes and we purchased a lot
of stuff but we did get back on our feet
and start paying it all off and now we
got about 20,000 in there but most of
that's medical the only thing that's not
is one that's 10,000 on the truck that I
was upside down on okay um now when you
tell me the house was rent owned it's
the house in your name no sir okay
so you truly have not transferred the
title yet no sir well I don't I don't
know what you're I don't know what your
contract says with them and you probably
need to have someone look at that and
with these folks because you I don't
think you're going to be able get
financing with what you're telling me
you might and the best way I can tell
you to fix that is called Churchill
mortgage and see if they can pull a
miracle off here but don't go borrow
money at fifteen or twenty percent
Interest to do this deal to help these
people out who paid cash for a house
you'd be better off just to go rent
something else lose your 15,000 and let
these people sell their house then you
would to overpay for the house or get a
horrible interest rate while you're
broke is still in debt right yeah I
don't want you to have to move but don't
do this deal it's already a stupid deal
it's already a bad bad deal very poorly
structured you're really deeply at risk
here and you know and I'm afraid for you
that you're going to lose this money is
what I'm afraid of
but because I'm afraid that that your
contracts probably poorly as poorly
written as this deal is structured and
you're probably screwed but you know
find out what the contract says talk to
Churchill mortgage and see if you can
get it refinance or get a financing deal
on it at 120
don't pay a dime more than 120 for this
house and and that needs to be your
financed amount actually show on paper
that you paid 135 and they've already
accepted your down payment of 15 that
might be able to help you pull this
together but if you can't get the credit
to refinance or to get financing on this
then you simply can't buy the house in
which case you may not be able to do
this deal in which case you might lost
your 15 thousand because you may be
moving so that they can sell this house
so that the system oh very poorly done
I'm so sorry for you guys but man you
may not miss here hey you guys Rachael
Cruz here hope you are enjoying the Dave
Ramsey show and did you know that I have
my very own YouTube channel yes that's
right kind of better than the Dave
Ramsey channel don't tell them I said
that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you